[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you want to
understand a country's military take a
look at what its officer corps
is reading military officers aren't just
war fighters they're trained to be
thinkers even intellectuals some of them
have advanced degrees
in russia officers above the rank of
colonel are required to read a book by a
russian nationalist called alexander
dugan
called the foundations of geopolitics
dugan's book envisions a eurasian empire
with russia at the center of it and then
outlines a way to achieve that
in china meanwhile recruits are told to
read the origin and goal of history
it teaches that china is successful
because its culture is superior to the
west's
now you might not agree with them but
these are serious books and they promote
the national
interests of the countries whose
officers read them that's why they're
assigned
and that makes sense so with that in
mind what are american military officers
reading these days well let's see
a subliterate pamphlet on how the united
states is a disgusting immoral country
that must be changed immediately and
forever
that tract is entitled how to be an
anti-racist it is written by a former
university of florida professor
called henry rogers who now that he is
rich and famous goes by his
revolutionary name
ibrahim x kendi the book is garbage
actually it's worse than that not only
is it embarrassingly stupid it is
poisonous
candy's premise is as simple as he is
any system that produces
unequal outcomes must be racist period
that's it that's the entire thesis
and kendi applies it to everything if
some people make more money than other
people then the economy is racist
if ibram ex candy decides there aren't
enough black astrophysicists
then astrophysics is by definition
racist
if it rains in a black neighborhood but
not across town then what you're
watching is weather racism
actually kenny didn't really write that
probably because he has no detectable
sense of humor
but there's no question that he believes
it the book is that militantly dumb
so how do we respond to all of this
racism in the united states well kendy
provides a solution quote the only
remedy to racist discrimination is
anti-racist discrimination he actually
wrote that
in other words his book against racism
promotes racism now you'd think that
might be a red flag for people
contradicting as it does the founding
principles of the country as well as
basic human decency
but no the people in charge love the
book it's all over corporate america
you can probably pick up a free copy
it's your hr department tomorrow morning
if you want
but the military you can't
imagine the us military would assign a
book like that
recommended to every sailor in the u.s
navy well yes
actually on tuesday congressman jim
banks of indiana demanded an explanation
for this from the chief of naval
operations admiral
michael gilday here's how it went
candy's book states that capitalism is
essentially racist
and kindy is clear that racism must be
eliminated so yes or no
do you personally consider advocating
for the destruction of american
capitalism
to be extremist here's what i know
congressman so yesterday racism in the
united states navy admiral
you recommended every sailor in the
united states navy read this book
it's a yes or no question i'm not
forcing anybody to read the book it's
on a recommended reading list admiral
did you read the book i did
admiral you said you read this book what
part of this book is redeeming
and and qualifies as something that that
every
every sailor is critical about his own
journey
as an african-american in this country
what he's experienced
let me ask you again admiral do you
expect
that say after sailors read this book
that says that the united states navy is
racist
that we will increase or decrease morale
cohesion and recruiting rates into the
united states navy
i think we'll be a better navy from
having open
honest conversations about racism
open and honest conversations about
racism
well that would be nice but it's an
amusing line coming from someone who
claims to have read kendy's book
as gilday says he has open and honest
conversations are racist candy said that
many times
so let's say open and honestly you
decided that you cared more about the
way people behave than the way that they
look
let's say you took a martin luther king
at his word and judged people by the
content of their character not by the
color of their skin
if you were to do that ibram ex candy
says you were a racist quote
the claim of not racist neutrality is a
mask for racism the language of
colorblindness is a mask to hide racism
a colorblind constitution for a white
supremacist america
that's the military's reading so no open
and honest conversations are not allowed
in kennedy's america
here's the choice you admit you're a
racist or else
you're a super-duper racist that's his
position
it sounds pretty deranged honestly in
fact it sounds like
an extremist ideology just the kind the
military is always warning us about
keep in mind that tonight right now the
pentagon is investigating national
guardsmen who have posted
unfashionable opinions on facebook about
the last election or may have voted for
donald trump
so with all their investigators running
around looking into people's thought
crimes how closely have they looked
has the pentagon looked into ibram x
kennedy have they checked his social
media history
actually congressman banks asked gilday
that question watch
in college candy stated that white
people are a different
breed of humans
and are responsible for the aids virus
yes or no do you personally consider the
conspiracy that white people started
aids to be an extremist belief
sir i'd have to understand the context
that is a simple question
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say admiral
this is a book that you've recommended
every sailor in the united states cherry
picked quotes
from somebody's book i'm not gonna do
that
do you consider the statement that white
people created aids and extremists david
i can't comment on that
i need the context for that so admiral
gilday what a mediocrity
will not defend the man he's just been
promoting
to the entire us navy now that's
odd that once you dig a little you can
see why he doesn't want to talk much
about it
not long ago kendy was invited to speak
at the aspen ideas festival a place
where ideas go to die
a room full of academics waited to hear
his wisdom during the question and
answer session
one of them dared to ask the most basic
question of all how are we defining
racism
how do you define it now you'd think
ibrahim x kenny would be ready for that
question but he wasn't
here's what he said you talked about the
importance of defining racism
but i but i unless i missed it which is
possible i don't
i didn't hear your personal definition
is there is there one that you would
offer us like how do you define racism
sure so racism i would define it as a
collection
of racist policies
that lead to racial inequity that are
substantiated by racist ideas
sure a collection of
racist policies that lead to racial
inequity
that are substantiated by racist ideas
so racism is racist stuff
whereas kennedy puts it and we're
quoting now it's a collection of racist
policies that lead to racial inequity
that are substantiated by racist ideas
end quote right but how are we defining
racism ibra max kendy
couldn't say despite making a bountiful
living on the topic getting rich
talking about racism he hadn't thought
how to define the word now in a serious
society
everybody listing everyone in the room
would have walked out and found
something better to do bird watching
maybe
that's racist well the so-called
intellectual on stage turned out to be
an idiot
so they should have left but they didn't
they just laughed nervously they were
worried they said something about what
had just happened if they pointed out
that the former henry rogers is in fact
a fraud
they would be denounced as well this is
how mediocre people control
entire societies with implied threats go
along or we'll punish you so they don't
say anything
the funny thing is in his own book candy
admits that he himself
is a racist here's a definition quote
white democrats stood aside and let bush
steal the presidency on the strength of
destroyed black votes
bush's team transitioned that winter i
transitioned into
hating white people white people became
devils to me but i had to figure out
how they came to be devils so this is
the man that
admiral michael gilda it's hard to
believe that admiral michael gilday has
any power in the united states military
but he does
and this is the man admiral michael
gilday believes the entire u.s navy
should study imagine working for someone
like
admiral michael gilday most normal
people cannot even imagine that
so they're leaving the military one
marine told us that military a military
history training session was
replaced with mandatory training on
police brutality white privilege and
systemic
racism he reported that several officers
are now leaving his unit
citing that training another service
member told us that their unit was
required to read white fragility by
robin d'angelo
which claims and this is a quote white
people raised in western society are
conditioned into a white supremacist
worldview
an airman told us their unit was forced
into a racist exercise called a
privilege walk where members of the wing
were ordered to separate themselves by
race and gender
in order to stratify people based on
their perceived privilege
it's depressing if you think about it
good people driven from military service
many of them serving generationally
because their fathers and grandfathers
did but having to leave
now purely because of the extremist
ideology
of its leaders it's crushing if you
think about it
but it's also scary for all of us we
need the military
the pentagon is in the department of
education it's not the dmv we have to
have it
it's essential to the survival of the
country
but the commissars in the biden
administration don't care they're not
slowing down
they are intensifying the political
purge in the ranks
nasa just announced its new mission has
nothing to do with space
the new mission is about applying the
principles in ibrahim kennedy's book
the new mission is equity
at nasa we're on a mission of equity
launching opportunity
equal opportunity to challenge and
inspire
to learn and thrive to reach those we've
never reached before
to use science data and technology
to advance equity to shatter boundaries
and break down barriers across america
to create a better future
we hope you'll join us on this mission
a mission of equity are you going to
join the mission of equity
can you define it hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else